freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ist wieder soweit einen tag lang
nur ins fenster produkte essen das erste
kam übels gut bayerisch an wir haben
irgendwie über 500.000 aufruft bekommt
das haben auf youtube kollegen gesehen
haben es auch gemacht finde ich aber
cool und ja ich habe hier schon unser
frühstück liegen es ist im weiteren
sinne gesehen in fenster produkt und im
noch weiteren sinne gesehen ein
frühstück schokolade von joko
winterscheidt ich weiß nicht ob ihr das
gesehen habe irgendwie super krass auch
draußen mit außenwerbung beworben so und
falls ich frage mich das frühstück es
gibt wirklich viele viele innviertler
produkte aber fast nichts was man
frühstücken kann außer vielleicht der
boulevard aber die hatte ich ja schon
falls ihr noch ideen habe immer gerne
die kommentare vielleicht manchmal sogar
noch einen dritten teil heute zum
beispiel gibt es echt viele geile sachen
auf die ich mich freue
also ich setze mich jetzt mal ein pc ich
bin nämlich heute den ganzen tag im büro
und dann frühstücke ich schokolade
jetzt kommt also gleich wie gesagt ein
bisschen untypisch frühstück im mir
überlegt dass das ganze ein bisschen
spannender ist bewerte ich jedes produkt
was ich heute teste ich probier s mal
die beiden sorgen ich weiß nicht ob es
gibt vier verschiedene ich habe jetzt
zwei geholt zum 1
kermani sieht haselnüsse café biscuits
und bc sehr fans sie auf jeden fall die
kombination bei der schokolade dann
birne braune karamellisierte man darauf
heute nicht mehr machen also erst die
andere irgendwie auch relativ teuer mit
zwei euro 80 habe ich glaube ich bezahlt
pro tafel
damit habe ich nicht gerechnet ich
wusste nicht dass ich weiß ich habe mich
wirklich nicht besonders das informiert
ich wusste auch nicht kippt ist so also
so steht der polare ein bisschen neu
gedacht finde ich eigentlich cool also
weiße schokolade dominiert das ganze
vollkommen pc ist ein bisschen komisch
und schokolade also wir sehen falls sie
es nicht kennen das ist dieses weiße
zucker zeug was man beim bäcker oder so
bekommt was einfach so also eine ganz
eigene pulvrige konsistenz ab ist aber
auch dem gletscher also wenn man bei
schokolade steht ist das geld aber ich
finde so die philips drängen nicht so
wirklich was positives dazu bei sondern
diese pcs halt akkus für die textur ist
ganz heiß aber ich mag dich dominierter
vor die weiße schokolade und jetzt
unsere sorte
dunkle schokolade mit birnen brownie
kanalisierten handel
mache auch gerne dunkle schokolade
glaube wenn ich einer der wenigen aber
wir probieren
hmm ich möchte die bilder echt fast ein
bisschen aber name gefällt mir besser
als die weiße alles in allem frühstück
wie gesagt ein bisschen notlösung gebe
ich dem ganzen acht von zehn ist lecker
ist auch gut als auch von sehr guten
bewertung aber es ist nicht üblich spec
und für zwei euro 80 tendieren wir auch
bisschen q 7 von 10
kommen wir zum vormittag zu essen
welcher wird schon vor hunger darauf
habe ich mich sehr gefreut wir sehen uns
bei der zubereitung also dann leute
willkommen zum mittagessen und freue
mich sehr darauf ich bin schon häufig
daran vorbeigelaufen dass viele der
straße das ist dönerfleisch von lukas
podolski
das ist irgendwie für mich schon so eine
kleine revolution dass man den abgleich
im supermarkt kaufen kann und haben
häufig das gefühl dass durch diese in
münster produkte mein häufiger sind sie
auch bei einem etwas höheren preis punkt
kann man irgendwie kann ja so ein
bisschen innovationen in den markt
bringen kapitza ist und zu knusprig das
hier gab es in der form so weit ich weiß
garnicht und ja das machen wir jetzt
bereiten wir zu lange da ist ja einer
der besten bürger in deutschland habe
ich letztens mit platz 6 oder sowas und
ich bin gespannt ob es genauso lecker
wird wenn ich hier zu hause ist
bei mangel habe ich schon zwei mal
gegessen von gästen das ganze aus ich
hatte einfach salat käse gekauft
juli gekauft aufgekauft tomate gekauft
wie man alles klein posten unsere ziele
an die wir viertel erwarten dass du noch
vielleicht werde ich pack das aber
erstmal aus hier weil darum geht's ja
ich meine das ist der star vom gericht
bot bett ist eine ordentliche portion
kostet aber auch 3 50 bis 4 euro also
ist schon ordentlich meinen dafür
kaufmann oder kriegt man an vielen orten
in deutschland einfach ein schöner
ganzen dünner mann mit den ganzen andere
sachen außen rum ist es im prinzip
eigentlich genauso wie ein bisschen
teurer war denner aber ist es etwas
besonderes dass man zu hause zubereiten
deshalb bin ich dann gab es eine fein
absolut es ist kalt bleibt dass ich
meine das ist ja immer ein bisschen
höhere preise ganz wichtig tomate immer
seife
ich frage mich ob das von der gerät
geschnitten wurde oder ob der mission
mensch danken dass alles nur ein
bisschen schaafs geht sie weiter
öffentlich lieben halt einfach
schafstädt auch boehner
das will das auch schon durchgebraten
lange bevor ich jetzt mit den anderen
vorbereitung fertig bin haben wir uns so
an getötete tasche die leute lieben
sky.de juli brauchen den großen
besucherstrom dann arioli rein
ordentlich soße kommt unser all die
bilder fleisch die leute liebeskugeln
not los dass sie keine automaten hinaus
gespannt was selbst um einen döner
mindestens sagen wird das sind raus
verlangt
das kann sich sehen lassen oder das
hüttenbrenner auf jeden fall ich finde
damit wenn auch die drei monate wieder
gerechtfertigt ich meine das ist halt
größer als was man überall bekommt ja
einfach das wichtigste vergessen damit
er noch was trinken ich habe es noch
nicht probiert noch keinen einzigen weil
er dazu wir merkten wir haben wenig
traditionelle internetlink melzer aber
dazu problem ihr rad weder dave noch ich
haben jemals probieren und braten oder
party kanal und ich weiß auf jeden fall
das tanzverbot über 100 euro dafür
ausgegeben hat weil er es so sehr liebt
okay das ist krank was möchtest du ich
nehme legen kann die wassermelone für
mich ja sagt kommen ihre region als
erstes ich weiß nicht lange gewartet
dass wir den bildern zu panik geriet nun
als erstes ein gradmesser niveau ist
schon mal klar ich finde ich sehr gut
geht geht's in richtung grüner
technologien checken was mal schmeckt
nicht super künstlich sehr leicht
vorgreifen richtig gut sich zu
guttenberg hat also kaffee oder
wahrscheinlich sein team war es der tag
habe ich ein gutes händchen für produkte
ich bewerte die nach dem essen aber
erstmal müssen wir in diesen john
boehner reinalter
passt gut der ich bin das heftig dafür
dass man in zehn minuten selbst
zusammenbasteln kann die pille ist halt
lange nicht sogar diese und selbst
gewannen damit zu tun haben aber
wirklich erstaunlich gut das war heftig
wenn ich finde in not ob man würde kann
unser schmecken ob das jemand frisch vom
spieß geschnitten hat worauf man das
angebratene die lederstraße der fällt so
auseinander also ich würde mich nicht
beschweren wenn ich das das dürener
bekommen will dass man 39 spex
vielleicht mit tendenz zu acht aber
baker und das auch karten kassiert
nämlich auch noch bis freitag ist wegen
dieses videos freunde es wird zeit für
den kleinen snack zwischendurch hält
jetzt schon sehen rocks chips hatte beim
letzten video auch schon aber das ist ja
eine brandneue sorte suite barbecue und
die werde ich natürlich auch testen wenn
erstmal will ich mich ja durch alle drei
bestehenden geschmäcker durchgetestet
und ich habe sie natürlich abgespeichert
in meinem kopf ich liebe diese videos
ich habe langsam ein bisschen schiss bei
teil 3 könnte vielleicht eng werden wir
müssen auf jeden fall wirklich produkte
in die kommentare schreiben
vielleicht reicht aber die 523 keine
muslime das sind die chips riechen
tatsächlich sehr süße street view steht
ja schon drauf aber die sind richtig
richtig suite das wieder kommt der
typisch was das für ein chip der das
werk komplett riesig ich glaube ihnen
kriegen ich meinem mund capuano krach
also ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich
schon mal solche chips gegessen habe
also ich finde man kann wirklich sagen
dass rob strip dicker und knuspriger
sind als normale chips also wirklich die
sind auf jeden fall sehr speziell
dies trieb barbecue ich bin ähnlich der
riesige täter ist also ich mag sie gern
wer macht nicht gerne chips ich würde
sagen mein aktuelles rating ist patrick
hardge mit barbecue york wien und mehr
sein
also je mehr ich davon esse bis mit
klassischer acht sie waren auf jeden
fall wichtig so viel kann ich sagen und
die tüte ist schneller weg als man
gucken kann in den ultimativen hardware
lifestyle zu leben muss man nicht nur
chips essen sondern dazu auch energy
drink trinken das hier ist ja super drag
racing von felix felix von alan
spielkind racing sonderedition hiermit
unterschritten habe ich nicht einfach so
gekauft und ein gemeinsames kriegt man
das weil ich war bei den rewe
ein kaufladen da wird nicht gefunden
dann hat er kommt vorbei polyana also
ich hab heute bei felix selbst abgeholt
und jetzt bin ich sehr sehr gespannt auf
den test was man direkt aufgefallen ist
da ist fruchtsaftkonzentrat ich weiß
nicht wie es bei red bull oder so ist
aber dass auf jeden fall kein saft knapp
ein viertel ist tatsächlich sagt
ferdinand ok richter lies ich probiere
ich bin irgendwie meisten drauf so
spannend weil die anderen sachen habe
ich so irgendwie schon mal gehabt glaubt
man gar nicht das was ich erwartet hätte
also kannst du das ist nicht so viel
zucker pro liter habe ich 12 500
milliliter das hat sechs kann sofort
aktiv zum beispiel dollar
red bull hat zehn gramm zucker pro 100
milliliter das sind 6 und ich finde man
schmeckt es aber es ist nicht unangenehm
doch wenn ich irgendwie geil also es ist
sehr erfrischend wenn ist ein auch so
ein bisschen besteht braucht 32 prozent
ist für mich auch wieder was neues muss
man wirklich sagen bist ein geiles
produkt gefühl ich finde ich schade dass
ihr das nicht gehen und kaufmann
programmen ist könnt ihr gerne auf dem
reden kommt kriegt von ihnen ein wenn
ich mich freue
zwischen diesen ganzen ungesunde sachen
zumindest das gefühl zu haben ein
bisschen was was du in die richtige
richtung geht zu trinken also kriegt nur
in 9 von mir wirklich sehr leid ich bin
zu hause und arbeite gerade ich muss
noch eine sache essen abendessen lieber
selbst mal gibt es eine games thurella
pizza für mich aber eine hatten wir
schon innovation im boden mit suzuki ich
glaube das ist die erste pizza mit
zurück dessen werde und ich liebe es
youtube krass muss ich wirklich sagen
ich finde es youtube ist so du hast die
wenn man erst es so du willst lecker
aber man ist danach auch pat deshalb
habe ich mir das bis zum abend
aufgehoben
ich weiß jetzt rein in hofen und freue
mich schon sehr darauf das krönende
finale
die grazer sie ist immer sorgt für den
sound und hier ist nicht drin aber ich
habe große pflegen für diesen raum
sie ist nicht sehr groß aber dass keine
reha mittlerweile ich werde jetzt mal
der sitcom pariert hat graf oder die sup
board als lecker aus richtig geil wird
zu einer der krassesten tiefkühlpizzen
die ich gegessen habe
das ist ehrlich heftig mit zukunft ist
wieder eine innovation
das kriegt von mir 19 wieder leute das
zwar unfassbar lecker aber ich bin ein
bisschen traurig dass das vielleicht das
zweite und letzte video von der reihe
sein wird kommen immer weitere produkte
aus und ich freu mich auf jeden fall
auch das was kommt wieder mal drops an
alle die heute mit dabei waren sehr
leichte produkte die auf den markt
gebracht hat weiter so ihr seid eine
gute präsentation für die internet-szene
dass wir weiter schmecken wir sind zum
nächsten video wieder macht's gut und
scharf